l'opposition sort de la trêve premières
critiques contre le projet de françois
mitterrand d'assouplir la loi pasqua sur
l'immigration la réforme du code pénal
pour quand les juristes y travaillent
mireille delmas marty professeur de
droit est notre invité le drame de la
petite aurore ballotté entre sa famille
d'adoption et ses parents qui l'avaient
abandonné le procès s'ouvre lundi
l'arménie trois semaines après le
tremblement de terre après le choc la
survie au jour-le-jour reportage de
l'équipe d'antenne de la plus belle la
plus rapide est maintenant la plus
grande
florence joyner griffiths sacré athlète
de l'année
bonsoir l'arménie 20 jours déjà et
peut-être un miracle ce soir les
sauveteurs ont retrouvé aurait retrouvé
il faut le dire au conditionnel encore à
spitak 17 personnes vivantes en muret
depuis le des tremblements de terre dans
un silo à grains elle aurait survécu
justement en mangeant ces graines un
véritable miracle je le disais en
arménie 20 jours après les plaies ne
sont pas refermées il ya eu le choc du
tremblement de terre il y a maintenant
la survie au jour le jour pour tous les
arméniens sans abri l'équipe d'antenne 2
s'est rendu à lénine à cannes c'est la
plus importante des villes sinistrées
il y aurait là bas plus de 40 mille
morts pour cette seule ville
beaucoup plus que ce que disent
officiellement les soviétiques
rémy roche reportage
partout des petits groupes autour d'un
feu il faut d'abord lutter contre le
froid regard vide
ils attendent sans savoir quoi la nuit
tombe
cela rentre dans un garage crasseux
qu'ils ont investi ali et quelques
photos celle de ceux qui ne seront plus
jamais avec eux et comme une litanie une
nouvelle fois il raconte le coup de
tonnerre et puis le ciel qui tout à coup
leur tombe sur la tête
les arméniens 10 les morts sont partis
le malheur est pour nous l'horloge de la
place lénine figé sur lors de la
catastrophe
depuis c'est une forme de survie qui
s'installent pour ceux qui n'ont pas
voulu quitter la ville malgré
d'insistantes recommandations
officielles
partez leur dit on il n'y a plus rien
plus de travail plus d'école plus de
commerces
laissez nous reconstruire vous
reviendrez ensuite
mais il reste pourquoi est il est
reversé rues défoncées de distribution
de nourriture en distribution de
vêtements
un simple examen fait peur population
encore traumatisée qui prend d'assaut
les quelques dispensaire installé par
les occidentaux
jusqu'à 160 consultations par jour pour
chacun de ces médecins qui découvrent
des malades à vide des conseils de la
médecine étrangères et de ses
médicaments inconnu pour la plupart
enfin une scène encore 100 fois répété
vingt jours après le séisme
un homme sa mère et un bulldozer sur
l'un des innombrables chantier de
déblaiement
il fouille dans ce qu'ils ont localisé
on ne sait comment dans cet
amoncellement de gravats comme leur
appartement et bulldozer attend sans
impatience mais le chantier doit avancer
l'homme n'est pas à la recherche d'un
bijou ou d'un souvenir
sa femme et ses deux enfants sont encore
sous les décombres
comme des milliers de cadavres qui en
armes et 10 n'ont toujours pas été
dégagés
sans transition maintenant l'annoncé
d'une réforme des lois sur l'immigration
en france c'était l'un des voeux
prononcés par françois mitterrand dans
son discours de nouvel an l'application
concrète ne s'est pas fait attendre
puisque déjà pierre joxe le miso
l'intérieur a pris des dispositions pour
adoucir la loi pasqua sur les conditions
d'entrée et de séjour des étrangers en
france quelles dispositions
isabelle staes cette carte de séjour
tous les immigrés souhaite l'obtenir
elle est désormais accessible à ceux qui
vivent en situation irrégulière en
france
chaque demande sera examinée
individuellement ce qui ne garantit pas
qu'elle sera acceptée
même chose pour les étrangers mineurs
qui ont fait leur première demande hors
délai soit plus de huit jours après leur
seizième anniversaire
d'autres mesures concernent les
étrangers ayant des liens familiaux en
france ainsi les conjoints de français
et les parents étrangers d'enfants
français
ils ont un an à compter du 1er février
pour demander leur titre de séjour
pourront enfin régularisé leur situation
les jeunes étrangers majeurs ayant
rejoint leurs parents avant le 7
décembre 84 et en dehors de la procédure
de regroupement familial
pour l'instant le pouvoir de reconduire
à la frontière un immigré clandestin
reste une simple mesures de police
administrative
il faudra une nouvelle loi pour modifier
cette disposition
voilà l'opposition est sorti de la trêve
de noël pour réagir aux propositions du
président de la république alors déjà le
front national a été le premier à réagir
très vivement d'ailleurs est aujourd'hui
à l'udf et le rpr on parle d'un piège du
président de la république jean-louis le
scène mais il aura fallu attendre plus
de 48 heures à la droite pour se
ressaisir après les propos tenus sur
l'immigration par françois mitterrand
quarante huit heures ce devra être un
délai suffisant pour atténuer le ton des
réactions
or que constate-t-on depuis la fin
d'après midi la virulence de toutes les
réactions de droite alain juppé au nom
du rpr déclare tout bonnement que
l'initiative du chef de l'état va à
l'encontre de l'intérêt national
jean claude gaudin pour l'udf reprend
monsieur mitterrand de souffler sur les
braises du front national et de devenir
dès lors un excellent agent électoral de
jean marie le pen bref tout le monde
hormis le centriste bernard stasi qui en
appelle à la sérénité pour traiter le
problème de l'immigration tout le monde
dénonce un coup politique du président
de la république
en fait dans toute cette affaire la
droite est bien mal à l'aise
d'un côté elle ne peut pas désavouer la
loi pasqua voté par ses élus sous le
gouvernement chirac
d'un autre côté elle ne peut pas se
renier au point d'en mettre en branle
des listes communes avec le front
national pour les prochaines élections
municipales
l'allocution du président de la
république ressemble à s'y méprendre à
un piège très politique
en tout cas la droite le crois
aujourd'hui les voeux du président sont
peut être d'ores et déjà exaucé au delà
même de ses espérances
mais les réactions les plus
intéressantes sont sans doute celles
recueillies sur le terrain voyez
l'exemple de dreux c'est une ville
symbole où il y a une forte population
immigrée une ville à majorité de droite
où le front national est puissant
enquête
henri elie marcel martin 35 %
d'étrangers à dreux selon les
associations d'immigrés 26 tout juste
d'après la mairie
qu'importe le chiffre exact tant il est
vrai qu'ici au moins un quart de la
population est aujourd'hui concernées
par la modification des dispositions de
la loi fasse quoi les immigrés donc
satisfait de cette nouvelle sans pour
autant saisir encore la portée du
message présidentiel
si vous voulez leur d'égalité at il noté
c'était très bon pour les trajets miguez
très bon à dreux dans la cité des chats
ma roue pour habite une quarantaine de
communautés à majorité pakistanaise et
d'afrique du nord
les immigrés vivent sans trop savoir ce
que concrètement ils obtiendront les
autorités françaises pour leur faciliter
l'accueil et l'intégration sur le
territoire national au niveau papiers
administratifs je pense je pense en
particulier à la communauté pakistanaise
qui ont des graves problèmes au niveau
départemental ce sera la préfecture à la
sous préfecture pour obtenir des papiers
pour retourner chez eux en vacances
outre je pense que concrètement ça peut
accélérer les choses en dehors de toute
considération politique même son de
cloche du côté de la mairie pour toi
majorité de droite
chez les élus locaux la prudence est de
rigueur pour eux deux préoccupations
essentielles d'abord chaque mois sur le
marché du travail chiffres officiels 60
nouveaux immigrés d'autre part il y à ce
que l'on ne peut pas vraiment
comptabiliser les clandestins il est
évident que la volonté du maire est très
aiguisée dans le sens d'une immigration
contrôlée d'une immigration canaliser
chez lui dire et de l'absence totale de
lutte ou du moins contre l'immigration
clandestine
ainsi donc à dreux d'un côté comme de
l'autre c'est d'abord la tente et
surtout la vigilance quant à la
réalisation concrète des voeux
présidentiels l'on peut se demander en
effet quels bénéfices la population
d'immigrés pourra-t-elle tiré deux mains
du nouveau transfert d'autorité du
pouvoir judiciaire aux dépens des
préfets le drame de la petite aurore
imaginer aurore à 4 ans elle a été
abandonné par sa mère à 10 mois mais
pendant trois ans ensuite elle a trouvé
un véritable foyer dans une famille
d'accueil
hélas en juillet dernier la justice se
fondant sur la loi du sang l'a rendue à
son père un homme qui avait eu quelques
problèmes avec la justice depuis cet
homme lui interdit de revoir sa famille
d'accueil où elle avait été heureuse
alors même que la famille d'accueil a
normalement un droit de visite et
qu'aurore veux tu y retourner lundi
prochain la sphère repasse devant la
justice anne gainsbourg
c'était en juillet dernier ce jour là
aurore apprend qu'elle doit s'en allait
quitter celle qui est devenue sa maman
oublier la famille qui l'a recueilli à
l'âge de 10 mois
les trois premières années de sa vie
aurore les a passés ici à sainte ces
jouets elle n'a pas voulu les emporter
certaine que justice comme elle
l'appelle l'écouterai un jour à 4 ans
elle a choisi
c'est là qu'elle veut rester là dit aux
juges ça signifie quand on n'a pas le
droit à la parole
le fait que monsieur bédié était
plusieurs fois condamné à de la prison
ferme
83 la prison ferme
c'est un des éléments figurant pour
enfants et cela n'a pas empêché ni
l'étude les éducateurs ni la cour
d'appel d'avenir
monsieur était effectivement il a cédé
des 683 et pourtant cet impair mois
d'octobre il a disparu trois semaines
puisqu'il était en prison et pendant ces
trois semaines
aurore a également disparu il n'allait
plus à l'école si son père aujourd'hui
lagarde d'aurore sa famille d'accueil
elle a obtenu un droit de visite et
d'hébergement droit refuser chaque
dimanche vous nous laissez l'embrasser
pourquoi non parce que quoi
malgré les appels malgré ses pleurs
aurore ans et séquestrée rouge est tout
à fait honte de ce qui se passe le tout
les dimanches je vis extrêmement main
les pêcheurs milian choix à faire c'est
à dire on nous allons dimanche
nous savons que nous y faisons tout à
fait mal très mal
nous savons aussi qu'elle sait qu'on
continue à l'aimer que nous continuons à
nous battre que nous tenons absolument à
ce qu'elle soit respectée à ce qu'elle
soit traitée en individus en objet car
les certificats médicaux sont là qui
témoignent des sévices sexuels dont
aurore c'était plein malgré cela
l'éducatrice l'a laissée chez son père
cela fera presque six mois lundi
prochain lorsque la cour décidera à
nouveau de l'avenir d'aurore un autre
fait divers un haut fonctionnaire de
vendée s'est donné la mort le soir de la
saint sylvestre jean françois bayart
jitze a voulu donner à son geste fatal
une dimension dramatique il s'est tiré
une balle dans la tête dans le bureau de
philippe de villiers président du
conseil général de vendée
monsieur jean n'a pas supporté d'avoir
dû abandonner son poste de directeur des
services administratifs lorsque philippe
de villiers est justement devenu
président du conseil général ce dernier
philippe de villiers s'est dit
profondément ému de cette affaire
enquête
michel mon comté jean france achevé en
six ans d'activité au sein du conseil
général de vendée jean franck ayache
vite avait su se forger un rôle capital
au sein de cette administration on
aimait à le surnommer parfois avec un
brin de jalousie
le président bis mais dans les conseils
de région comme partout les présidents
changent et si le précédent
michel crussy voyait plutôt d'un bon
oeil cette collaboration étroite avec
jean franck ayache beats philippe de
villiers lui avait préféré à peine élu
choisir un collaborateur à la
personnalité peut-être un peu moins
encombrante une démarche banale somme
toute dans cette fonction
mais une démarche que jean franck
l'alliage vite n'a pas pu supporter
lorsque j'ai été élu et conformément à
l' usage
j'ai fait savoir à jean klein et chips
qu'il serait conformément au droit remis
à la disposition de son ministère
d'origine au ministère de l'intérieur
il m'a d'ailleurs remis entre les mains
conformément à l' usage son poste le
jour même de ma prise de fonction mais
chacun comprendra et je pense que vous
le comprenez que devant un tel drame qui
est un drame personnel familial
partageant la détresse de toute une
famille s'impose le silence et le
respect dû à mort mais le seul fait que
jean franck ayache vite chez choisi de
mourir dans le bureau même de l'homme
qui l'avait démis de ses fonctions
suscite ici toutes les rumeurs même les
pires
on murmure qu'il n'y avait pas de place
dans cette région pour deux hommes de
premier plan
voilà deux faits divers ils passeront en
justice et peut-être feront ils l'objet
d'une condamnation il y en a cinq mille
chaque année en france des condamnations
quelle référence pour la justice et bien
cela le code pénal tout simplement
ce code pénal il est vieux il date de
napoléon vous le savez le début du 19e
siècle
bien sûr il a été modifiée par petites
touches mais le président mitterrand il
l'a dit encore dans ses voeux souhaite
une refonte complète de ce code pénal
alors avec nous mireille delmas marty
qui est professeur de droit qui est
aussi membre de la commission de refonte
du code pénal bonsoir madame c'est vrai
tous les juristes le reconnaissent le
code pénal est dépassé mais ce qui est
dépassé dans beaucoup de domaines
écoutez des très vieux quand même parce
que il après 200 ans et c'est preque
même pour un code
ça fait beaucoup alors il est dépassé
sur certain poids il reste des
archaïsmes par exemple la mendicité
c'est un délit dans le code
mais je crois que si le plus grave c'est
surtout le désordre
comme vous l'avait dit il ya eu des
réformes il y avait des réformes à des
moments différents on assurera ajouté
des textes on enlever d'autres
et à l'heure actuelle on a l'impression
d'un grand désordre d'une très grande
difficulté d'accès à cette loi pénale
que nul n'est censé ignorer ou 486 un
projet avait déjà été présenté au
conseil des ministres même accepté juste
avant les élections
et finalement donc il avait été
abandonné mais il donnait déjà les
grandes lignes du nouveau côté l'un à
tout à fait tout à fait c'est le projet
déposé par robert badinter dont qui
contient déjà trois livres du nouveau
code pénal et c'est une partie déjà très
importante il ya beaucoup de travail de
fait alors ce qu'il faut c'est continuer
le travail la vie 86 la commission a
continué à travailler dessus alors alors
le garde des sceaux actuelle a relancé
des travaux de la commission il a donné
une nouvelle impulsion à la commission
en lui demandant en octobre dernier de
se remettre au travail de re lire en
fête les premiers livres parce que entre
86 et 88 ya eu des réformes donc il faut
en tenir compte
et puis surtout de travailler au niveau
suivant
dans quel sens va dans la halle à la
rédaction de ce qui va suivre alors je
crois que ce qui est intéressant moi ce
qui me fera beaucoup c'est cette
coïncidence de date
ce code pénal il va commencer à discuter
comme cela a été annoncé en 1989 et ça
me parait symboliquement très important
parce que faut il ya deux choses dans ce
code pénal ya l'idée de modernisation
qui est importante mais il ya aussi
peut-être surtout l'idée que c'est un
code
inspiré par les droits de l'homme c'est
en ce moment je crois que vous êtes
présidente de la commission justice
pénale et droits de l'homme les stocks à
cet effet et au fond en créant cette
commission justice pénale et droits de
l'homme
le garde des sceaux actuelle le
poursuivre et la tâche entreprise par
robert badinter aussi ce temps à
souligner le lien étroit qui lie à entre
le droit pénal et les droits de l'homme
au fond un code pénal protège les droits
fondamentaux de la personne et je crois
que c'est très important de voir que la
discussion va commencer en 89
parce que les droits de l'homme tel
qu'il était conçu à l'origine dans le
code pénal
eh bien ils ont évolué il ya des valeurs
nouvelles qui sont apparus il ya le des
valeurs importantes comme le respect de
la dignité de la personne qu'on ne
percevait pas d'écho temps de d'acuité
en 1810 et qui maintenant apparaissent
et se projette code pénal le déposer en
86 il marque l'importance de ces valeurs
nouvelles ce sera loin aboutir je crois
que raisonnablement ça peut être fait en
quelques années et que ce soit un homme
bien disant non je pense que peut-être
cinq ans en cinq ans en votant tous les
ans 1/2 livre on doit pouvoir arriver à
une refonte complète
il ya toute une partie du travail qui
est déjà fait ou à terme de projet donc
si le parlement commence la lecture
immédiate de la partie déjà rédigé je
pense qu'il peut arriver à voter un ou
deux livres par an et ça donne une
échéance de cinq ans merci mireille
delmas marty
merci beaucoup confusion en allemagne à
propos de l' usine d'armes chimiques
lydienne les allemands ont-ils oui ou
non aidés à la fabrication de cette
usine des journaux américains les accuse
une société française est aussi en cause
et tout cela à quelques jours de
l'ouverture de la conférence de paris
sur le désarmement chimiques justement
philippe rochot patrice pollet
voici l'intérieur de lusine dont on
parle tant à 65 km au sud de tripoli
rapt à ces laquelle est implanté un
complexe gigantesque qui serait capable
d'après les experts de produire deux
sortes de gaz le gaz moutarde qui
attaque les poumons les yeux et la peau
il ya un autre gaz encore plus dangereux
le sarin qui provoque la mort presque
instantanément par destruction du
système nerveux 38 tonnes de ces deux
gaz pourrait être produit chaque jour
dans cette usine
les différents éléments nécessaires à sa
construction auraient été acheminés via
hong kong et singapour et acheter pièce
par pièce dans plusieurs pays à travers
le monde
de douze au total dont la france selon
les experts américains
l'entreprise de dietrich deuxième
spécialiste mondial pour la fabrication
de cuba haute pression est impliqué mais
ce soir au siège de l'entreprise en
alsace au dément catégoriquement avoir
travaillé pour la libye de son côté le
colonel kadhafi affirme que son usine ne
fabriquera que des produits
pharmaceutiques et accuse les états unis
d'ingérence dans ses affaires
intérieures en allemagne de l'ouest
cette affaire fait grand bruit
une entreprise spécialisée serait à
l'origine de lusine libyenne il me
faisait chimie une petite entreprise
familiale montré du doigt par les
américains mais qui se défend d'avoir
fourni à la libye la matière nécessaire
pour la fabrication d'armes chimiques
nous ne savons même pas où est la libye
nous n'avons pas les connaissances
nécessaires
l' affaire pourrait s'arrêter là si le
gouvernement allemand ne s'en mêlait pas
danser mise au point d'un côté le
ministère des affaires étrangères
affirme que le parquet fédéral a ouvert
une enquête ce qui est ensuite démenti
de l'autre le ministère des finances
déclare qu'il est sur cette affaire
depuis vendredi alors qu'il n'a commencé
son travail que depuis ce matin et que
de toute façon il n'a rien trouvé mais l
affaire est d'autant plus grave que le
chancelier kohl aurait été informé des
soupçons américain dès le mois de
novembre dernier lors de son voyage aux
etats unis
la sphère du boeing de la panam suite
chaque jour apporte de nouvelles
révélations après l'attentât le parquet
de francfort a confirmé tout à l'heure
que certains colis embarqué à francfort
n'avait pas été inspectée c'est sans
doute parmi ces colis que se trouvait la
bombe
cela pose bien sûr le problème de la
sécurité de la surveillance des bagages
nous avons déjà la rade et nous en avons
pardon largement parlait déjà
la police française vient d'acquérir un
nouvel appareil canadien un appareil qui
permet de détecter les explosifs dans
les bagages je n'ai pas encore la
panacée mais il sera sûrement très utile
michelle perrot
jusqu'à présent un chien spécialement
dressés était seule en mesure de
reconnaître la présence d'explosifs dans
les bagages ce privilège lui est
désormais disputé par cette machine
d'origine canadienne ici la truffe et
électroniques
d'abord elle renifle le colis afin de
repérer l'éventuelle présence de
matières suspecte en ce cas
l'introduction d'une sonde permet le
prélèvement d'échantillons d'air qui
sont ensuite insérées dans l'appareil
pour être analysées une minute et demie
plus tard la machine affiche les
caractéristiques de l'explosif détecter
200 appareils de ce type existent
actuellement dans le monde
ils permettent en outre la détection et
l'analyse de la drogue
oui toujours à propos de cette affaire
du boeing assez rafat le leader de l'olp
et aurait accepté de coopérer avec les
services de renseignement américains
pour retrouver les auteurs de l'attentât
le fbi ayadi d'accor gilles rabin
quétier et revolver à la ceinture comme
n'importe quel combattant palestinien
mais déjà la gravité affecté qui
convient tout responsable politique de
dimension internationale reçu comme un
chef d'état à ryad par les émirs
d'arabie
yasser arafat inaugure le chantier de la
future ambassade de palestine tout faire
pour préserver sa nouvelle
respectabilité diplomatique selon deux
quotidiens britanniques
arafat aurait proposé de mener sa propre
enquête pour retrouver les auteurs de
l'attentât contre l'avion de la panam
yasser arafat se serait même déclaré
prêt à envoyer un commando pour punir
les coupables
s'ils se confirmaient les soupçons qui
pèsent sur des organisations
palestiniennes
réaction immédiate du fbi américain
si cette information se confirme la
proposition de monsieur arafat est très
importante très constructif dans
l'actualité internationale encore les 30
ans de la révolution cubaine et le
naufrage d'un bateau mouche au brésil
mais tout d'abord nous restons proche
orient avec les nouveaux troubles dans
les territoires occupés par israël
véronique taveau nous vous affrontements
cisjordanie à gaza 11 palestiniens
blessés par les tirs des soldats
israéliens
hébron à ramallah des groupes de jeunes
manifestants brandissant le drapeau
palestinien se sont heurtés aux forces
de l'ordre une vague d'incidents qui
survient après l'expulsion de treize
palestiniens vers le liban israël leur
offre auch d'être à l'origine des
soulèvements dans les territoires
occupés depuis décembre 87 le début des
troubles
quarante neuf palestiniens ont ainsi été
expulsés vers le liban
le marxisme-léninisme ou la mort cuba
fêté en grande pompe le 30e anniversaire
de sa révolution un discours très
virulent de fidel castro un discours
symbole c'est à santiago de cuba du
balcon où il avait le 1er janvier 1959
proclamé la victoire de la guérilla que
le numéro un cubain s'est exprimée
fidélité aux principes socialistes
réaffirment et un message clair mais une
priorité sortir le pays de la crise
économique
fidel castro a décidé de tendre la main
aux américains mais également aux
devises étrangères
la polémique après la fuite dans un
bateau surchargé qui n'aurait jamais dû
prendre la mer 70 personnes ont pu
regagner le rivage à la nage
des rescapés qui aujourd'hui et moi cent
trente et une personnes à bord pour une
capacité maximum de 100 passagers
les gardes-côtes avec ordonné au
commandant du bateau de rentrer au port
une mise en garde sont n'ont pas tenu
compte les responsables du navire accusé
aujourd'hui de négligence bilan 51 morts
et toujours neuf personnes portées
disparues et ceci encore washington
capitale du crime la capitale fédérale
américaine détient depuis peu un triste
record en un an 3 166 personnes ont été
tuées cela fait un meurtre par jour en
88 proportionnellement c'est plus que
dans aucune autre ville américaine plus
que new york ou que chicago principales
causes la drogue
jacquat bouchard reportage la ville en
état de siège
c'est le titre d'un programme télévisé
quotidien d'une station de washington
sur la violence dans la capitale
fédérale
certains soirs à cinq minutes de la
maison blanche c'est presque beyrouth
pour l'ambiance sonore
stars venues au crime
washington s'est bien rattrapé le 31
octobre elle avait déjà battu son record
annuel d'assassinât avec 288 morts
l'hécatombe s'accélère alors que dans la
plupart des grandes villes américaines
touchées détruites miami los angeles et
là plutôt tendance à diminuer la police
multiplie ses opérations dans les
secteurs chauds les quartiers pauvres à
majorité noire transformé en sanctuaire
du marché de la drogue
quinze mille arrestations liées au
trafic de stupéfiants en 1987
cette année elles passeront le cap des
20 milles
l'argent coule à flot surtout les
trafiquants s'équipent d'armes de poing
de gros calibre et de mitraillettes
hommes sont en infériorité par le nombre
et par l'armement se plaint maurice
turner le chef de la police locale
la secte des plaques moslem les
musulmans noirs a déclaré une guerre
sans merci aux trafiquants de drogue
depuis quelques mois ses hommes sanglés
dans leurs costumes uniforme ont nettoyé
certaines rues où la police ne se risque
et plus il se présente désormais en
sentinelle avancée de l'islam à
washington en france encore cette
information qui ne fera pas plaisir à
ceux qui empruntent les autoroutes les
autoroutes gratuites ne sont pas pour
demain je vous le dis tout de suite en
principe elle devait devenir gratuite en
92 et bien la gratuité totale est
reportée à 2010 et pour faire bonne
mesure les péages augmenteront cette
année de deux et demi pour cent en
moyenne le temps des bilans le temps des
classements ce début 89 les journaux
sportifs ont rendu leur verdict
l'athlète de l'année est une femme cela
n'était pas arrivé depuis neuf ans vous
devinez qui est la plus jolie mais aussi
la plus musclée
celle qui court aussi vite que les
hommes c'est flou jo florence joyner
griffiths gens ma mère
la star des stars florence griffith
joyner ampleur sur la plus haute marche
souriante et éclatant quelques minutes
plus tôt en finale du 100 m une athlète
au sommet de son art physiquement et
musculairement parfaite et la même
personne qui quatre ans auparavant à los
angeles n'occuper alors que la deuxième
place sur le podium
une métamorphose impressionnante sur
laquelle les spécialistes se pose
beaucoup de questions c'est le fruit
paraît-il du travail de son entraîneur
de mari
une évolution que l'on ne peut
s'empêcher de comparer à celle du
canadien ben johnson
malheureusement l'ex roi du sprint a été
déchu pour dopage
al'inverse florence griffiths est une
reine une vraie une star une championne
exceptionnelle qui a cumulé une large
victoire sur 100 m et un non moins
impressionnant record du monde sur 200 m
ajoutez à cela une médaille d'or et
d'argent en relais cela vous fait un
palmarès aussi long que ses ongles de la
main
florence griffith joyner c'est le
sourire de la femme épanouie lojo le
sourire de l'athlète 1988 la reine
incontestée des jeux olympiques
j'ajoute que deux autres sportifs sont
distingués meilleur rugbyman du monde
d'après notre confrère midi olympique
c'est serge blanco un français et puis
meilleurs footballeurs de france est
bien là encore c'est un français c'est
stéphane paille
d'après l'équipe et quelques autres
journaux j'ai un tiercé à vous donner le
tiercé de demain les pronostics pour le
tiercé de demain bien sûr c'est sur
l'hippodrome de cagnes sur mer c'est un
peu au sud
alors voici ce pronostic il ya vingt
partants pirette propose le 8 le 5 le 4
le 9 le 3 le vin le 18 et le 17 fin de
cette édition prochain journal henri
sannier ce sera vers 23h15 demain
télématin 6h45 avec roger zabel trois
journaux complets d'information sept
heures sept heures trente huit heures
avec bien sûr catherine ceylac et marco
tu mentes et puis gérard morin recevra
7h45 dans les 4 vérités maître soulez
larivière à propos de la réforme du code
pénal dont nous venons de parler à
demain soir